for months now fatima has been
struggling to live with the physical
scars
of what she went through in her hometown
of homera a refugee in umrahkuba camp in
sudan's kadar state
says she was about to give birth when
amhara soldiers raided the hospital
she says all the health workers fled
leaving those in critical conditions
like herself to deal with the soldiers
the doctors were preparing to do a
c-section on me but when i woke up i
found a wound bigger than a normal
cesarean on my belly
an amhara soldiers were around when i
asked about my child
they said they'd taken it and asked me
to leave or die
more than 63 000 refugees have now fled
to sudan's gaddarif and neighboring
casella states
the conflict integra started in early
november when the ethiopian government
launched a military campaign against the
regional tegri people's liberation front
it came after an attack on a government
military base following months of
tension between the two sides
while the number of refugees coming into
sudan has seen little increase over the
past few weeks
aid organizations say more than a
million are internally displaced inside
degree
the u.n says aid convoys to the region
are being blocked as fighting continues
between the two sides
despite the ethiopian government
claiming victory over the tigre people's
liberation front
in late november the un says
4.5 million people in the region are in
need of relief
with hundreds of thousands facing severe
malnutrition
it's described what's happening in tigre
an unfolding full-scale humanitarian
crisis
in a video smuggled out of the ethiopian
capital last month
the head of the ethiopian orthodox
church and native to graham
became the most senior voice to call
what's happening in the region a
genocide
it followed a us government report
describing the conflict as an ethnic
cleansing of tigrayans
[Music]
i'm not sure what the tigray people did
wrong what their crimes are
i'm not clear why they want to declare
genocide on the people of tigre
i do not know why they want to wipe the
people of tigray from the surface of the
earth
the whole world should know this
ethiopia's government has rejected the
claims
saying that it's ready to work with
international human rights experts
to investigate any claim of rights
violations the pope has called on the
parties to the conflict to stop the
violence and protect civilians
but many in the region say his appeals
are likely to be unheard
the pope is he's a religious leader but
nobody will listen to him
because he's great plus is religious but
they don't
they don't accept him because the
eternal soldiers they don't have the
religion they don't have they are
they're religious they don't have
religion totally they don't believe it
they don't believe it they are doing
very very very guilty things in here in
utica
those who can are fleeing to sudan those
inside tigre can only wait for aid and
for the conflict to end
thousands of people have already been
killed directly by the conflict
eight organizations weren't that with
their access blocked thousands more
could die from starvation
hippomorgan al-jazeera god out of state